on the campaign trail mayor Pete Buddha
judge frequently uses religious rhetoric
he says American politics can be divided
into good people and then sinners and
you can guess which side Republicans are
on now mayor Pete is getting into
biblical scholarship as well in a recent
interview he explained how actually the
Bible says that unborn children are not
alive and so abortion is okay you go
through the New Testament for sure and
every other word that comes out of the
mouth of Christ is about things like
helping those in need and you got a
Republican Party dedicated to its
opposite there will be a reckoning over
that now right now they hold everybody
in line with this one kind of piece of
doctrine about abortion right which is
obviously a tough issue for a lot of
people to think through morally then
again you know there's a lot of parts of
the Bible to talk about how life begins
with breath and so even that is
something that we can interpret
differently
Ryan Glassman is senior pastor at
Community Church of God in Clio Michigan
he's also the brother-in-law of Meir
Buddha judge and called on his
brother-in-law to repent after his
latest remarks pastor husband joins us
tonight
pastor thanks for coming on you are by
your own description non-political and
you're not seeking to attack your
brother-in-law but I felt it would be
worth getting your view of the theology
involved in this explanation of abortion
what do you think of it absolutely thank
you Tucker for this opportunity to come
on here and I would like to make a plea
to people to judge my brother-in-law
that he would reconsider his position
and the way he is misrepresenting
Scripture to push this a pro-abortion
platform that he's pushing I like to
make a play with him that he'd
reconsider and actually open his Bible I
actually ask all people to open up their
their Bibles as they're watching this to
in turn to Psalm 139 specifically verses
13 through 16 and how can you read those
passages that talks about we are
fearfully and wonderfully made in the
image of God intrinsically you were
woven together
woman's womb I know how you can read
that and come out of that with any other
understanding that we that life begins
at conception and what's even more
alarming is that there's Christians who
would stand like mayor Pete wood and say
that God condones that God says that
abortion is okay according to Scripture
that's just absurd in outlandish to me
so his contention as I as I am
interpreting it is that the New
Testament says that abortion is fine
until the child draws breath in other
words really through the end of the
third trimester do you just want to be
absolutely clear in this is there any in
your view Christian interpretation of
the Bible that leads to that conclusion
absolutely not
you know I would just encourage all
people to look at Scripture again back
to Psalm 139 that we are created in life
begins at conception you know we need to
get away from you know this isn't a
political thing to me this is a
spiritual thing to me and this isn't the
denial of it's this is a God issue this
is a spiritual not a political issue and
to be honest with you Tucker this isn't
even my opinion or Pete's opinion this
is what does God say what is the word of
God truly say in the Bible as being
misrepresentative and just misuse to
push a pro-abortion agenda and that is
alarming it's disgusting it's
frightening and it just it needs to stop
it is all of those things I agree with
you completely have you said this to
your brother-in-law I have not spoken
this directly and I hope he sees this I
hope all people watch this and he will
reconsider he will change his position
he will actually open up the Bible and
read through scripture what scripture
actually says you know we need to create
a culture that speaks of human life and
human beings who have value we are
commanded right by Christ Himself to
uphold the dignity and respect of all
human life we we need to stand for all
the born and all the unborn so you just
said you you would ask your brother and
watch Oh
scripture and read this I mean his
presidential campaign is I've been
watching it is based on the idea that he
is deeply versed in Scripture that he's
a deeply Christian man he's running and
explicitly he says Christian campaign
mm-hmm well I don't know how anyone I
mean what happens we see in second Peter
chapter four that there's a time coming
where people will turn away from sound
doctrine and accumulate teaching that
it's their ears basically what that
verse reads is people we're living in a
time now as we see with Mayor P that
people are drifting away from sound
doctrine to make that scripture say
whatever they want to do to manipulate
and distort Christianity and what the
Word of God says to meet their own
desires in the own pleasure you know
really it boils down to this tucker's
what I believe is people either seek
power or they're gonna stand up for the
powerless in people the the baby in the
womb in the mother's womb is powerless
it's the most vulnerable person a human
life in so people have to make a
decision he has to make a decision are
you gonna stand up for the most
vulnerable are you gonna seek the power
in distort scripture to meet your own
political agenda and that's exactly what
we're seeing not just with Pete with the
whole Democratic Party right down though
that's exactly right yeah it's I think
it's nicely put let me just to end on
this so people that judges married to
your brother have you spoken to him
about this I am very open about all of
this and I hope all of them see this
I am very unashamed of the good news of
Jesus I I'm a pastor I share the gospel
politics is secondary to me I'm about
sharing the good news of Christ and I
hope all people watching this that I
really I challenge Americans as we as
these democratic debates come up here in
a couple days in I'm assuming this topic
is gonna be brought up that people would
stop and they actually think and
actually think what are we talking about
you we're talking about human lives here
we're not talking about the EM we're not
talking about just a little blob of
cells we're talking about human life and
are we gonna stand up for the dignity
and respect where people stop and really
think what do you really believe not
what your party believes you know be
wonderful to see a Democrat come on say
you know I'm not gonna
go down the trail that all the Democrats
are going down I think that the life in
the womb is valuable and has intrinsic
value I'd like to see someone stand up
and do that you just saw tulsi gabbard
today a Democrat say she thought third
trimester abortion was wrong it's cruel
and most people know that anyway yeah
master I'm glad that you came on tonight
thank you very much and I hope that you
get a chance to talk to your
brother-in-law
thanks yes thank you